Anything to get inside Neil, the grass Tyson's head. Oh, Hey,
I'm going to take it.
I'm going to take an animal and pay 90 bucks and a strap up and put on my
seatbelt inside.
Side of the head. It really, it really is.
You're going to see what I'm thinking when I'm thinking.
I mean, that's yeah. That's to me, it's like, I,
cause I always think about that with great thinkers. Like you it's like,
what do they sit and think about? Because it's like, I know like me, I'm like,
I just feel like there's just cartoon music playing in my head all the time.
I'm just an idiot. And I'm like hit by an anvil.
What about one of the greatest thinkers of our time? So that's something like,
even you explain it and I'm like, I was on the fence and I'm in there.
Well, so here's it. Here's one of the sentences that I shared in the, in,
in the, in the course it's one of the great challenges in life is
knowing enough about something to think you're right.
But knowing not enough about that same thing to know that you're wrong.
Wow. I like that. I like that answer a lot.
Of people in that zone. Yeah. Who will take a flat earth or for example,
they all know they're right.
That's because they don't know enough to know that they're wrong. Right.
And the people trapped in that sort of Eddy, it's a, uh,
it's a term, it's an intellectual turbulence where you think, you know,
what's going on and you don't.
So part of the challenge of the educator is getting them to understand why
they're not thinking it's right. And you can't just say, Oh, you're an idiot.
You don't know.
Cause then they'll dig their heels in stronger when we know this, right. If you,
if someone wants to fight you, you're going to fight back.
So it requires some art of persuasion. You say, well,
why do you think that? And have you considered this? And what about that?
And then they arrive at the right answers themselves.
And then they take ownership of their new knowledge. Otherwise I don't want,
I don't want anybody to say this is true because Tyson said, so right.
Then I failed as an educator. Right.
Then you see it's more about cult the personality or not the truth.
Exactly. I had somebody who was sure, a full grown adult man. Sure.
We never landed on the moon. And I said, okay, so this is here I go. Ready?
Do you ever get frustrated? Just go. You're stupid.
Stupid help you. But you're dumb. The human being.
And I'm sorry.
When he said this, I said it is time. Okay. So,
so we had a conversation and I said, you know, here's the Saturn five rocket.
You saw the rocket. Yeah. Do you know where the astronauts are doing?
Like the top inch of that rocket, everything else is fuel. Where.
Do you think they will go on with all that fuel? You can.
Calculate how much fuel that is. It's enough to go into orbit, leave orbit,
go to the moon, orbit the moon, come back to them and come back to earth.
It's that much fuel. Okay. So where do you think they were going to that?
He out on amp
go totally went old dime. You were going to,
gosh, where are you going to whole foods?
So optimal Ballantine ale, New York city rep.
That's a big ad in Yankee stadium was a Ballantine was about that.
What's the three, the rings, uh, with the, um, um, uh, Michelob,
Michelob, Michelob. Anyhow. So, so, uh, so,
so I, so I try to work through some reasoning and you know what he said to me,
he said, and he know, if you tell me we landed on the moon,
then I'll believe it. And I said, no, that's not how this works. Right.
Because that's the culting of information, right? No,
it's not true because I said, so it's true because it's true.
And you need to understand why. Right.
And when you understand why I don't ever want you to reference back to me ever
again, you should be able to understand, take ownership of it. Right. Right.
And I know I've succeeded. If, once I've taught you what I've taught you,
you forgot that. I even, yeah.
Sure. With you,
I'm going to have me and my four year old daughter gonna watch her masterclass
change in my even way. Even my four year old daughters,
we're going to start thinking like Neil from right now, start them early.
She's four years old and we're going to do it enough.
We're starting talking science immediately. Now. Why do you tell,
what was she saying that to you? Stop reading your book.
Who was saying that to her? I know her mom always tells me he's like,
where is she? You know? I'm like our, daughter's eating a book. He's like, yeah,
look at you. That's what you're doing. Do you think there's a,
like an assault on objective reality? Now? What, what is going on?
How did this happen?
Because people, I don't know who to blame. Uh,
let me, let me be a little heretical. Let me first blame psychologist. Okay.
I'm not really want to blame them. I'm just doing that for, for the fun of it.
Okay. So what is the colleges? Psychologist will tell you your feelings matter.
Okay. They're important.
And now I feel like there is no global warming.
So all of a sudden your feelings are elevated to the level of fact, right?
And you vote. So you get to control the influence of your feelings on everybody.
And so I don't mean specifically emotion, happy or sad. It's just,
you want things to be a particular way. And, and,
and you feel like it should be,
it shouldn't be what the scientist is telling you.
The fact that that has given equal credence against objective truth is one of
the great tragedies of modern society.
And it's the beginning of the unraveling of an informed democracy. Okay.
So now let's pull psychologists out of that. Cause I just did that for fun.
I think the somewhere in the educational arc we're missing,
uh, in the science class, you don't just teach,
what is you need to teach you don't to teach what is known,
you teach what science is as an enterprise,
what it is and how and why it works. What does it mean to be skeptic?
What does it mean to understand information and trust that information,
this information relative to that information. All right.
And so that's missing in the school system. And so I don't,
if you think there was this flat, I'm not even going to blame you.
I'm going to say something happened in your school, in your, in your, uh,
in K through 12,
that needs to be changed so that we preempt this kind of thinking as we go
forward, by the way, in a free country,
you should bet with think what you want and say what you want.
But if you have power over others,
that's when objective reality matters because we all share the same objective
reality. Even if we don't share your personal truth.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about,
this is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boys,
where things get really wild.